oh so friendly hi good afternoon
everybody
okay a couple things at the top
we would like to announce that President
Joe Biden and first lady Dr Biden will
host president Emmanuel macron and Mrs
Brigitte makong of France for a state
visit to the United States on December
1st 2022. this will be the first state
visit of the Biden Harris Administration
it will underscore the deep and enduring
relationship between the United States
and France our oldest Ally our close
relationship with France is founded on
our shared Democratic Values economic
ties and defense and security
cooperation the leaders we'll discuss
our continued close partnership on
shared Global challenges and areas of
bilateral interest
this afternoon the president will
deliver remarks at the third meeting of
the competition Council the president
will highlight progress made on his
competition agenda in the last year
which is helping lower prices for
consumers raise wages for workers and
promote Innovation throughout the
economy at today's meeting the president
will also announce new action to Spur
competition among Airlines Expose and
limit Airline fees and most importantly
save money for American families add-on
fees hit the most vulnerable Americans
the hardest the president will highlight
how companies sneak fees onto bills
prevent customers from seeking the full
price of what they're buying up front
and how they used termination fees to
make it harder for consumers to switch
their service providers in fact the
median American household loses an
estimated five thousand dollars a year
due to lack of competition
the actions the president will announce
today are part of his commitment to
continue tackling that and bringing down
costs
tomorrow the president will continue
this focus with remarks at the at the
White House on how he is lowering health
care and prescription drugs are costs
for seniors and families across the
country and working to strengthen
Medicare and Social Security last year a
family of fours saved an average of
twenty four hundred dollars on Health
Care through the American Rescue plan
that President Biden signed into law and
now thanks to the inflation reduction
act which President Biden signed into
law about two weeks ago Medicare will
finally have the power to negotiate
lower prescription drug prices seniors
will see their out-of-park pocket costs
for prescription drugs limited to a two
thousand dollars a year
for decades big Pharma and special
interests had blocked Medicare from
negotiating low prescription drug prices
President Biden and Democrats in
Congress put an end to that through the
inflation reduction act while every
single Republican official voted against
it
not only that republicans in Congress
continue to advance legislation to cut
Social Security and Medicare and put
these programs on The Chopping Block so
President Biden will speak to all of
that and more tomorrow
I wanted to also acknowledge the
dangerous and backwards Court ruling in
Arizona Friday evening this is a
complete abortion ban one that forces
survivors of rape and incest to carry
their pregnancies to term and women with
medical conditions could face dire
health risks
Health Care Providers would face
imprisonment of up to five years for
fulfilling their duty of care
this band would take Arizona women back
to more than a hundred and fifty years
and subject them to a law from
1864. a time before Arizona was even a
state
Arizona is now the 16th state where
Republicans officials have stripped
women of their rights through extreme
unconscionable Statewide abortion bans
and republicans in Congress continue to
advance Senator Graham's proposed
National Abortion ban the president and
the vice president believe that Congress
must act urgently to codify Roe and
protect women's access to abortion and
health care for for millions of women
enduring these daily attacks on our most
fundamental rights the risks too many
risks are at stake
finally tomorrow we will be joined in
the briefing room by FEMA administrator
Dion Criswell who is in Miami today to
assess ongoing hurricane planning and
preparedness efforts over the weekend
the president approved Florida's
emergency assistant request as soon as
he received it and directed his team to
Surge federal assistance to the region
well before landfall FEMA has
prepositions supplies at strategic
locations in Florida and also Alabama
that includes generators millions of
meals and millions of liters of water
FEMA also has staff on the ground
supporting planning and preparation
efforts tomorrow administrator Criswell
will provide an update on the efforts
underway in Florida Florida to prepare
for Hurricane Ian as well as ongoing
recovery efforts in Puerto Rico and also
Alaska
we look forward to welcoming her and she
will be glad to give you the latest
information and of course take all of
your questions
thank you
um first um does Administration have any
reaction to former U.S security
contractor Edward Snowden being granted
by Vladimir Putin Uh Russian citizenship
so since I believe there have been
criminal charges brought against him we
would point you to uh to to the
Department of Justice for any specifics
on this
um I wanted to also ask you about your
announcement on the macron state visit
um this comes this announcement about a
year after things got a little bit bumpy
for a while and the relationship with
the office announcement
um I guess my question is why France
getting this first honor uh how much of
this is one I guess the relationship
come first full circle back to being in
good stand and was part of this about
repairing uh the relationship and then
separately from that
um it's a little bit late on an
Administration for the first state
dinner but obviously covet was around
what's the calculation and how did
Administration thought about now is time
to actually do one of these State
dinners
um so on your first question we deeply
value our relationship with with France
which is as I mentioned at the top our
oldest Ally with our bilateral relations
founded on shared Democratic Values
economic ties and defense and security
cooperation we work closely with France
on the full range of global challenges
as you all know including the war in
Ukraine it is for these reasons that the
president and first lady thought it was
important to welcome this close and
valued partner to the to the White House
for their first uh their first state
visit as you know uh president Marcon
and President Biden have had multiple
conversations over the president's first
19 months and have met a few times most
recently as you all know last week at
the at unga and so again this is a
valued deeply valued relationship and
one of our oldest allies on your second
question you're right kovid certainly
has delayed many of the in-person events
a president traditionally hosts at the
White House but the president and the
first lady have been welcoming foreign
leaders to the White House including on
working visits and official working
official working visits throughout the
administration but as you stated covid
has delayed many uh some of this as well
one quick housekeeping note on Florida
um you mentioned the FEMA plans has the
president spoken to Governor DeSantis
ahead of the storm does he plan to don't
I don't uh we don't have a any calls to
preview or that's locked in to share at
this time okay I want to ask you about
the the new poll that was out this
weekend this ABC Washington Post poll
which was 56 percent of Democrats want
the party to nominate someone other than
Biden and for people under 40 75 percent
want the party to pick someone different
um is the president concerned by this
how's he digesting a number like that so
as you know I'm I'm very limited on on
how I can discuss any kind of Elections
uh I will reiterate what we have said
many times from here what the president
has said many times even recently as
recently as these 60-minute interview is
that he intends to run uh don't have any
more announcements on that but look
the president will will say as I'm
saying right now is his focus is not on
himself self his focus is on continuing
to deliver for the American people after
taking action we just talked I just
talked about the inflation reduction act
how important Medicare is now going to
be able to negotiate be able to lower
cost uh for uh for our seniors and how
important it is cost is going to go down
as well as it relates to uh to energy
bills I mean these are things that the
president has done for the past 19
months making sure that manufacturing is
is resurgent we saw that in the New York
Times article and we have been able in
the first 19 months about 700 000 jobs
manufacturing jobs have been created
right here in this country because of
the work that this president has done
and you know we I said this at the top
we have done everything that we can
every the president has made lowering
costs for the American people a priority
has made the economy a priority for the
American people and you think about the
American Rescue plan plan Republicans
didn't vote for that you think about the
inflation reduction act Republicans
didn't vote for that in fact they put
forth an agenda that wants to take away
the the gains that we have made by
fighting uh by winning against one of
the most powerful special interest
groups again
this list here but the poll actually
shows that the president the president
is deeply underwater when it comes to
the economy is there anything the White
House plans to do differently do you
need to do it but midterms are in 44
days again I can't talk about the
midterms no no no no I'm I'm not what
I'm about to answer your question give
me a second here uh again I I have to
say this right I cannot talk about the
midterms from here because you did
mention the midterms what I can say is
and we talked about this in our August
memo we are going to go out there not
just the president the vice president
the cabinet secretaries you have
Congressional members uh in their
District as well and we're going to talk
about how we have delivered for the
American people here's the thing when
you think about Medicare you think about
social security you think about the
pieces of legislation that we have
passed they are are very popular with
the American people with Republicans and
Democrats and so that is also important
to note so look we're going to keep
getting out there the president loves
going out to to uh you know to States
across the country to communities across
the country talking directly to the
American people and that's what we're
going to do I understand what you're
saying about the poll I understand what
you're saying about the president's
numbers but what we are going to focus
on is how we are going to continue to
deliver for the American people
especially at the most important uh
things that matter to them lowering
costs making inflation a priority when
it comes to his economic agenda making
sure we don't leave anybody behind build
any common economy from the bottom up
middle out and that's going to be the
president's Focus
I'm praying to you does the White House
have a reaction to the school shooting
in Russia Today
oh of course um
uh we condemn any violence
that's something that the president
always calls out is is important that he
feels it's important that we speak out
especially when you hear about violence
in schools so I will leave it at there
I'd also like to return to a topic of
the approached on last week in the
briefing about the British prime
minister's economic plan the British
pound is falling significantly in part
also because of the fed's actions here
on the dollar but also in reaction to
her plan the president has often and
regularly criticized trickle-down
economics is he a fan of her plan and is
there a concern about the volatility of
the currency markets so I'll say the
first part is and she said this I
believe prime minister trust said that
uh you know when she was asked on one of
the Sunday shows yesterday and she said
that the United States is one of our her
our their closest allies and we will uh
say the same the UK is one of our
closest allies and so we will leave
their uh policy decisions to themselves
but to your question about the the pound
so on Friday as you all know the
president and the vice president met
with senior members of the economic team
and got an update on the global economic
developments as they regularly do our
economic team reported that because of
our economic strategy which is focused
on long-term growth and investment
increased manufacturing and fiscal
discipline we are able to navigate these
challenging Global times from the
strongest possible position the rest of
the American Rescue plan helped us
recover from within with with twin
health and economic crises we were
facing better than most other economic
uh major economies remember we are all
dealing with global challenges just
around clearly around the globe and as
the president's economic legislation
including the infrastructure law the
chips Act and the inflation reduction
act are encouraging investment right
here in the United States I just
mentioned a moment ago how 700 000
manufacturing jobs were created just in
the U.S in the last 19 months a lot of
that is because all of that really is
because of the work that this president
has done and that will make our economy
stronger and more resilient to the years
to come so again we feel that we're in a
better position to deal with the global
challenges
um and uh and I'll leave it there
yeah thanks Karina would these
co-workers in Ukraine being taken around
by armed escorts and forcing people to
fill out ballots on the spot should we
expect the United States to issue new
sanctions this week in response to these
sham referendums that are being
conducted so let me just first say that
we will never recognize uh recognize
this territory never recognize this
territory that this territory as
anything other than as part of Ukraine
uh this when it comes to the Sham
referendum the Sham votes that we're
seeing in the last couple days we will
continue to work with our allies and
partners to hold Russia accountable and
support Ukraine for as long as it takes
as far as what we are doing we are
prepared to impose additional Swift and
severe economic costs on Russia along
with our allies and partners in response
to these actions that we're seeing
currently if they move forward with
annexation we've been very clear about
that as you all saw on Friday G7
Leader's statement the United States
will never ever again recognize this
territory as anything than part of
Ukraine we stand with our partners
around the world in rejecting whatever
fabricated outcomes Russia announces and
you will hear more from us in the coming
days on this so there could be action on
that this week look we'll hear more from
us in the coming days again these These
referendums are flagrant violation of
the international law you heard that
directly from the president at unga last
week and it's an affront to the
principles of sovereignty and
territorial Integrity that underpin the
International System and are the
foundation of the United Nations Charter
you heard the president say that
specifically just a few like just a few
days ago
that we saw from Jake Sullivan and Tony
blinken all of these figures yesterday
about the catastrophic warnings that
they say that they've communicated to
Russia if Russia chooses to use nuclear
weapons in Ukraine does the United
States believe that even if it's still
low does it believe the chances of
Russia using nuclear weapons is higher
now than it was in February in March
given what's happened on the battlefield
so as far as any evidence or the chances
look we haven't seen that at this time
we take these threats though very
seriously but we have not seen any
reason to adjust our own nuclear posture
at this time so again haven't seen any
evidence of it but we take this
incredibly seriously
on the issue of the president speaking
with Governor DeSantis we saw them side
by side a little over a year ago when
they were together with the Surfside
incident and so forth does the president
think it's important when you have this
nature of a threat to millions and
millions of Americans to have a
conversation with a governor I know
there's a lot of administrative and
bureaucratic steps that are in place to
provide resources but does the president
believe it's important to speak to a
governor the president believes is that
it's important that Federal resources is
provided for the people of Florida that
is the most important thing to make sure
that we are there for them
in this time of need and that's why the
president reacted right away to make
sure that the that we are able to Surge
resources before and he did this before
landfall and so that is the most
important thing it's about the people of
Florida it's not about public officials
especially in this time uh and so again
the president as president of the United
States as president uh for uh for folks
in red States and blue States he's going
to keep that commitment and you have
seen him do that over the course of the
19 months when there has been extreme
extreme events extreme weather that has
happened again in blue States and red
States and he has done his job as
president to make sure that we are there
for for the people in the state is there
any concern if there is a perception
that there might be a politics or
personalities or disagreements among
individuals that would get in the way
not so much of the flow of the
information but if people are wondering
is there anything that could stand in
the way of the response if a president
and a governor might not speak he didn't
speak to the governor of Mississippi
during the Water Crisis with Jackson
thus far has not spoken to governor and
that's a perfect example Kelly when you
mentioned the governor of Mississippi
they you were right they didn't speak
and we still were able to deliver for
the folks in Jackson and for the folks
of Mississippi you had our EPA
administrator on the ground you had FEMA
administrator on the ground and not just
them but also folks who work for those
uh for those two agencies and you have
the Army Corps of Engineers and so we
put the full the full uh Power of the
administration we surged resources on
the ground to make sure that we did
everything that we can to help the
people of Mississippi this is the same
there is no difference here we're going
to do the same in Florida as we've done
in other uh in other states as I
mentioned administrator Chris Griswold
will be here tomorrow she is in Miami as
we speak current as I speak currently
and she'll be here and she will lay out
what we as an Administration is doing
for Florida and other and other in other
states like Alaska and any others that
need our assistance at this time and and
she'll lay that out and answer any
questions that you all may have
yeah I have a couple questions
um what is I know last week you were
asked about Puerto Rico in any plans of
the president
trip down to Puerto Rico is he planning
to go and provide some guidance on that
I'm having a little bit of a hard time
hearing you you asked last week about
the president
um possible travel plans you didn't have
anything to say last week do we have an
update on whether the president does
intend to travel uh we don't have any
anything to to preview at this time we
continue to closely monitor the impact
of hurricane Fiona is having on Puerto
Rico I just reiterate just a couple of
things for folks who may have missed
this but as you all know when he was in
New York uh the president announced the
federal government is covering a hundred
percent of the cost of debris removal
emergency protective measures for the
next month in this recovery the
President also increased critical needs
assistance from 500 to 700 to support
individuals and families with immediate
or critical need as a result of being
displaced from their primary dwelling
and as of today there are hundreds of
federal response workers on the ground
in Puerto Rico supporting operations
planning power Restorations debris
removal and urban search and rescue as
far as travel we don't have anything to
share at this time also on Iran we saw
continue to protests
and I know that last week we did get
indications from the state department
that there were efforts the United
States had taken to ensure internet
access remains available are there any
other measure steps the U.S government
is intending to take to support
protesters yeah I'll lay down the steps
for a second but I just want to make
very very clear here and we have been
very clear the US on on our position
with what we're currently seeing in Iran
the president stated at unga we stand
with the brave citizens and brave women
of Iran who right now are demonstrating
to secure their basic rights women in
Iran should have the right to wear what
they want free from violence or
harassment Iran must end its use of
violence against women for exercising
their fundamental freedoms there must be
accountability for masa's death what we
are doing I'll lay out a couple of
actions that we have taken as it relates
to the internet on September 21st the
Iranian government cut off as you know
access to the internet it for most of
its 80 million citizens as courageous
Iranians take to the streets to protest
the death of Masa amini the United
States is taking action to support the
free flow of information to the Iranian
women I'm sorry the Iranian people
specifically more broadly on September
23rd which was this past Friday the
Department of Treasury issued an updated
General license that will increase
support for internet freedom in Iran and
authorized technology companies to offer
the Iranian people more options of
secure outside platforms and services
with these changes we are helping the
Iranian people access tools that are
better equipped to counter the Iranian
government's effort to surveil and
censor and censor them as well if we
have any more information we will share
that with all of you
just a follow-up on your answer about
the UK pound so are you saying that the
administration doesn't think that
currency volatility volatility is so
serious right now that the US government
shouldn't need to take action right now
so look we continue we're going to
continue to monitor uh the global
markets uh what we are are laying out is
what the meeting that the president had
with his economic team how seriously
we're taking this uh how uh closely uh
that we are you know having
conversations uh with our team
and what we can speak to is what we're
doing here in the U.S our U.S strategy
economic strategy is focused on the
long-term growth and investment
increased manufacturing and fiscal
discipline has positioned our country to
navigate challenging Global times from
the strongest position possible again
we're going to continue to monitor uh
all of all as we we always say we
continue we monitor the indicate all
indicators will also monitor the global
markets as well but what I can speak to
is what we are doing here to to to take
on these Global challenges as we have
been for the last 19 months thanks and
then on the president hosting the
Atlanta Braves today wondering if you or
the president has any thoughts about
some of some controversial about the
team name the Braves name the so-called
Tomahawk shop any thoughts on so we we
believe that it's important
um to have this conversation uh you know
and uh and Native American and
Indigenous voices they should be at the
center of this conversation that is
something that the president believes
that's something that this
Administration believes and he is
consistently emphasized that all people
deserve to be treated with dignity and
respect you hear that often from this
President the same is true here and we
should listen to Native American and
Indigenous people who are the most
impacted by this
thank you uh two questions one in Italy
[Music]
do you foresee future cooperation with
the right-wing Coalition that won the
election in Italy yesterday
so um on the election specifically I you
know I'm not going to go and engage in
any hypotheticals right because we still
have some time here uh it's a it's a
NATO Ally as you know a G7 partner and
member of the EU so we will we will work
that with the new Italian government on
the full range of shared Global
challenges including supporting Ukraine
as they defend themselves against
Russia's aggression but but again I'm
not going to get into hypotheticals
again there are a NATO Ally a G7 partner
and a member of the EU
mobilization in Russia continues many
Russian men tried thousands of questions
and tried to leave the country and
hit on that some European countries
including politics and Poland turned
them back others argued that Europe
should welcome them and give them
Refugee status what's your position what
president what's President Biden's
possession in that and is the U.S
willing to Grant those men Refugee
status here in the U.S so I would leave
other country I would let other
countries speak to their own policies
I'm not going to speak to the to other
countries policies from here but what I
can say for our part for the U.S we have
been clear to distinguish between the
actions of the Russian government and
its armed forces in Ukraine and the
Russian people many of whom have spoken
out against this unjust War we see that
just in the last couple days as we see
the protest continuing in Russia so
anyone seeking refuge for persecution
regardless regardless of their
nationality May apply for asylum in the
United States and have their claim
educated on a Case by case basis that's
where that's how we see our role here
and our part in this
yeah thank you does uh President Biden
share zelinski's assessment that Putin
is not quote bluffing when it comes to
his threats about nuclear weapons so I
mean we've been very clear on this the
threat I
responsible
you've heard the president say this
you've heard the National Security
advisor Jake Sullivan he was most
recently on a few Sunday shows and and
the consequences of nuclear use would be
disastrous
for Russia and the world and Russia
would be a pariah on the world stage so
this is not new rhetoric we have heard
this before from Russia we have heard
this before from Mr Putin they have made
these threats before over the course of
the this conflict this past six months
or more we of course take it seriously
again we take this very very seriously
though I would add that Russia itself
has said many times that a nuclear war
cannot be won and should never be fought
this is something that they have said
including earlier this year in the P5
joint a statement as the president made
clear any use of nuclear weapons on any
scale should be this would be should be
and would be would be disastrous for the
world and would entail severe
consequences well and regarding these
catastrophic consequences that Lincoln
Sullivan yourself have said would occur
if there are nuclear weapons used I mean
can we assume that these would be
consequences Beyond sanctions that there
would be some sort of a military
response what more can you say of what
catastrophic consequences mean so look
um and
Jake Sullivan said this said this
yesterday as well is that we have had
private conversations he
the NSC and and his team has had private
conversations and uh and communicated
privately directly to to the Russians
and they understand that they understand
exactly uh What uh what those
consequences would be and we are not
going to lay that out in the public we
are not going to have these uh
negotiations or share these
conversations in public but again to
reiterate what uh our national security
advisor said just yesterday is that they
have made that very clear and spoken
directly to the Russians and they
understand are there any plans for
President Biden to relay that directly
to Putin in some way we don't have any
calls to preview at this time
welcome back thank you so um it's been
about a month since the president
unveiled his plan for the the 10 to 20
000 of student loan forgiveness I know
that there was going to be an
application available in early October
I'm just wondering if you can give any
updates on whether or not that's still
going to be we'll have something to
share on that very very soon on the
application process uh and the next
steps uh don't once we have that we'll
we'll share with all of you and several
State Attorneys generals are planning
you know support challenges once this is
unveiled what can you talk a bit all
about what is sort of going on inside
the administration to bolster against
this or
um so I leave that to the Department of
Justice I know that when we announced
the student loan relief they put out on
their website kind of a legal kind of a
legal layout of how they came to
making their legal determination so
again I'll leave it to to them but look
you know there's always a lot of noise
around the student loan debt relief and
and at the bot the bottom line is this
is going to give some breathing room to
many Americans tens of millions of
Americans this is going to be an
important uh important step forward in
giving people an opportunity to save
some money and put money down on the
house right to start their their family
90 of Americans who are going to be able
to benefit from the student debt relief
are making less than 75 000 a year so
this is an important we think we believe
is an important for Working Families it
is important for for people who are just
looking for a little bit more of um you
know a little bit more of help in their
everyday lives my second question is on
this framework House Republicans
unveiled last week should they take the
the house into God after the midterms I
know that senior Republican leaders have
been touting a lot of these different
bullet points investigation power hiring
more police officers the parent Bill of
Rights like what uh what what are you
all thinking as they keep playing up
their framework and giving interviews
about it I mean what is the specifically
about the GOP agenda or can you yeah I
mean I think I think the subpoena power
and the power to investigate is probably
I would imagine a concern inside the
White House but I'm wondering
um you know as you watch these sort of
these Republicans talk about it what is
the thinking look look our thinking is
we are going to focus on the here and
now we're going to focus on the wins
that we have been able to make for the
American people you all saw it you all
reported on it when you think about the
chip sacks you heard me talk a couple
times already about the inflation
reduction act you've heard me talk about
the American Rescue plan how that got
our economy turned back on I just talked
about the student debt relief that's the
what the president's going to be focused
on uh whether you know the GOP take the
house or not again I have to be careful
what I say from here from the podium
that's a hypothetical that we're just
not going to entertain at this point at
this point we're going to make sure that
we are doing everything that we can to
lower uh to lower costs and you know I
will say this Republicans are doing the
complete opposite they're not wanting to
lower cost for the American people again
voted against the American Rescue plan
voted against inflation reduction act
that helps lower cost for the American
people but again we're going to stay
steadfast and making sure that we
continue the work you know two o'clock
out can you take a few more yeah
all right it's been two months
shut down will be averted at the end of
this week so look and I've spoken to
this a couple of times uh we are we we
believe uh that uh this could be uh
averted this is not the first time that
we are in a position where uh you know
we're talking about the CR it was done
last year and it would it could be done
again this year so uh we uh we encourage
Congress uh to get it done
be talking to lawmakers this week to try
and push back over we don't have
anything for you to to preview at this
time on any conversations that the
president is having I can say this and
I've said this many times before our we
have our teams here in the various
departments who are having regular
conversations with members of Congress
and their staff in a bipartisan way
because this thing we think this is
something that should happen and needs
to happen
okay
um can you give us an update on USA to
Pakistan and can you also tell us um to
what extent the US is worried that
catastrophic flooding in the country a
country that's nuclear armed with a
history of military coups could lead to
political instability and security
so um would have to go back to the team
to get any more specifics on what we
have talked about already about the the
aid that we have provided for Pakistan
um we have been in close Communications
uh with with folks and making sure that
um as they're dealing with the flood as
the the people of Pakistan are dealing
with the flood that they have um uh you
know Aid uh especially from us don't
have any specifics on anything else that
uh Beyond of what we have already shared
but I'm happy to check with the team and
and lay out and get some more updates
for you is there anything you can say on
the kind of concerns for this the
humanitarian issue could lead to a
security I mean we always have that
concern that's something that we monitor
very closely uh just don't have anything
more more to share on what we've already
laid out
Senator Rick Scott has a bill that he's
proposing that essentially is supposed
to require universities with high
endowments to pay some of the financial
aid when it comes to tuition uh does the
administration have have they seen the
bill we were told by Rick Scott's team
that they sent a letter to the
administration have you seen the bill
and does the administration believe that
universities do have some type of
responsibility when it comes to lowering
the cost of higher ed so I have not seen
this bill I would have to talk to our
office of ledge Affairs on this
particular piece of legislation by Rick
Scott look we have been very clear and
so so has the Department of Education
Secretary the secretary there has said
you know has put into policies and
processes in place to make sure that
universities are are playing their role
in not raising costs on on students in
universities but I have not seen this
piece of legislation so can't comment on
it from at this point
thank you Kareem this President Biden
think America's big cities are safe
can you say more well we know that
deaths and robberies are up about 20 in
the first half of this here so I'm
wondering if he thinks America's big
cities are safe are you talking about
the New York Times story and
specifically or is that what you're
referring to the murder rate still 30
above its 2019 level they're all from
the Council on criminal justice so we've
seen some high profile examples of this
the Washington Commander's running back
was being mugged he got shot uh Karen
bass member of Congress had her house
robbed these are high profile people so
should
everyday Americans who are not in the
public eye feel safe so I'll say this um
that same story also uh stated that the
crime is complicated and multifaceted uh
look this is a president who has secured
historic funding to make sure that law
enforcement has what its needs
especially and he was able to do this in
the face of opposition from Republicans
during a time uh where uh where he
inherited a rising crime rate from the
previous administration the president
put forth the American Rescue plan and
in that very in that very plan there was
more than 300 billion dollars to go to
local local States and local cities to
make sure that they were able to hire
Law Enforcement Officers they were able
to hire you know firefighters they were
able to hire people that were critical
to their needs as they were dealing with
a pandemic Republicans voted against
that so I guess just the original
question does President Biden think
America's big cities are safe it is not
it is not a um
it is not a yes or no question it is
very much a question of what has he done
that's how we see the question is what
has he done to make sure that cities and
it doesn't matter if it's a big city or
a small City it doesn't matter if it's
in a red state or a blue State what
matters is that we have the funding and
we have done the work put the policy
forward to make sure that these cities
whether it's big or small have what they
need to protect their community and
that's what this president has done
again without the help of Republicans
and my last one on this chin saki says
that crime is a huge vulnerability for
Democrats why would she say that
so you know
um again I can't do electoral politics
from here as you know
but I I kind of I don't agree with your
character organization of what she
actually said uh but I'll say this and
I've already uh I've already said this
already the past few months what we've
been able to do is create a pretty much
Clear split screen of what we are doing
to deliver for the American people and
what Republicans refuse to do we are
making sure that that uh that we have
Medicare and Social Security and we make
sure that the farm the big Pharma is uh
is not uh upping cost for our seniors
right and making sure that we give them
a little bit of breathing room and you
know we have Republicans who want to cut
Medicare they want a sunset Medicare
they want to Sunset Social Security you
have this GOP agenda that was put out by
the house where they want to go after
the inflation reduction act which will
have an effect that will actually hurt
Americans and so I think there is a
stark contrast here that we've seen in
the past several months I would argue
the past 19 months and this is the last
question I know we have to two o'clock
we have to go that's great I just want
to ask you about this pretty
extraordinary open letter sent to the
president by the workforce of the office
of Inspector General at DHS they
essentially say that the inspector
General Joseph kafari should be removed
that uh he uh the workforce cannot
complete their mission with kafari in
his position they say that he no longer
has the support of the workforce he's
permanently damaged the reputation of
the office this is apparently the office
that the months sat on the news of the
January 6th the text message from the
Secret Service and according to reports
this summer blocked deeper
investigations into those text messages
has the president seen this letter does
the White House have to respond so we
have heard about some of the issues with
this particular Inspector General and
we're we're going to take a look at
those uh that's what I can share with
you at this time but as far as any
personal Personnel announcements I don't
have anything to share again we have
heard of some of these issues and I can
say to you from here that we're going to
take a look at them all right we'll see
you guys tomorrow thanks everybody